yes adele
we can hear you but yeah no it's been a
complete whirlwind
on sunday the grammy winner made a rare
appearance at this
oscars after party multiple images have
surfaced collected by fan sites of the
chart topper clearly having a good time
at the intimate affair
in one video adele is seen dancing to
the jennifer lopez and ja rule hit
i'm real
and while daniel kaluuya may have taken
home an oscar
his judas and the black messiah co-star
nabbed the award for best selfie of the
night
amber chardet robinson shared this pic
to her instagram story
these new images follow months of the
singer staying out of the spotlight
i'm here because i've had a lot of
heartbreak in my life first at 19 and
then
sort of famously at 21 and then even
more famously at 25.
adele was last seen publicly in october
when she hosted saturday night live
i know i look really really different
since you last saw me but actually
because of all the kobe restrictions and
the travel bans
i had to travel light and only bring
half of me and this is the half that i
challenge
she used the tv appearance to address
her stunning weight loss
and poke fun at questions surrounding
the release date of her next
album i know there's been a lot of
chatter about me just being the host
i've seen all of it like why isn't she
the musical guest and stuff like that
and there's a couple of reasons
my album's not finished and i'm also too
scared to do both
adele first teased new music in 2019
and rumor has it the album is coming
later this year
but a close friend has revealed he's
actually heard some tracks from the new
album
in january british comedian alan carr
called the songs he listened to
so amazing
[Music]
and adele's night outcome soon after her
divorce was finalized from ex simon
kaneki
in march the couple agreed to share
joint custody of eight-year-old son
[Music]
angelo